la petite entreprise familiale est
devenue grande
en 50 ans d'existence cordier s'est
implanté partout en france et les
camions ça fait toujours rêver
moi céderait conduira les camions c'est
grand alors que dehors tu y crois pas
c'est gros et c'est beau c'est bien
confortable et je suis étudiant à chalon
sur saône en bac pro transport et
logistique et je venais ici pour
demander des conseils
sur mon cv ma lettre de motivation
depuis les années 2000 le transport
routier a dû s'adapter en région
beaucoup d'entreprise couvrant tous les
domaines d'activités se sont créés
depuis les métiers de la logistique
jusqu'au transport de marchandises
on constate une majorité de pme les
grands groupes se faisant plutôt rare
est actuellement le secteur recrute
l'activité de recrutement aujourd'hui
c'est un des premiers enjeux des
entreprises de transport car aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas les véhicules qui manquent
mais c'est bien le personnel en
bourgogne franche comté le secteur
emploie près de 22000 salariés dont une
majorité en emplois permanents
reste que dans ce secteur les marges
sont faibles et face à la concurrence
européenne
chez cordier ont fait la chasse au
gaspillage nous avons investi il
arrivera dans trois mois chez nous à un
poste de simulation éco-conduite fixe
les chiffres c'est simple pour une
flotte chez nous de 350 moteur un litre
d économiser ses quatre cent cinquante
mille euros par an d'économies sont les
camions cordier totalise 42 millions de
kilomètres par an et quoi qu'on en dise
le transport routier a encore une longue
vie devant lui